video gear equipment when should you
upgrade what should you upgrade if
you're looking for ways to save time
increase productivity elevate your brand
and ultimately create better content
than this episode of the think media
podcast is for
you I've been on YouTube for 17 years
I've been doing video teleprompters
cameras tripods lenses all this
different stuff and I'm going to distill
a lot of my best tips and mistakes in
this episode and I'm going to make some
complex things simple so whether you're
Advanced or beginner I think you'll get
a lot of benefit as you listen to the
end and I'm going to be sharing a few
warnings and mistakes that people make
with gear that will save you thousands
of dollars and that will help you from
wasting time and making things too
frustrating and complex and a lot more
and so today's episode is brought to you
by thinkgear guide.com this is one of
the coolest things we've created at
think media it has an FAQ of the updated
cameras and microphones and lighting
that we recommend things always shift
and change so we have answered all of
your questions all in one place and
we're also doing a giveaway of a YouTube
studio and a camera and all of that is
at thinkgear guide.com so we'll link
that up in the show notes and I'll tell
you a little bit more about that later
so here's the big categories that we're
going to break this episode down into
we're going to talk about what are the
benefits of upgrading your gear what are
the three big elements a video what are
the four primary camera kits that you
may already be using or considering
upgrading to what is my video gear
upgrade checklist and then finally four
questions to summarize the entire
episode so you have some clear next
steps so let's quickly cover what are
the benefits of upgrading my camera gear
I think one of the main benefits is to
speed up your workflow and to save you
time a lot of times when we think about
getting a fancy camera we think about I
want my videos to look better to look
cooler to have the cool blurry
background those types of things but a
lot of times I think your dollars best
spent are spent on speed if you can have
a camera that is so easy to work with
because of the way you can pull the SD
card out and then put it into a computer
that can edit your videos quicker than
your previous computer saving you time
is saving you money now another benefit
is of course improving your quality and
another benefit is elevating your brand
Paul Rand said design is the silent
ambassador of your brand and by Design
here I'm applying that to say the way
your videos look the way your videos
feel the way your set looks the way your
lighting looks this is an accelerator of
trust if you're a business professional
this can help you close business because
people take you more seriously when you
show up more professionally and people
take you more seriously when your design
and your video is on point now you know
here at think media we always talk about
the content value being more important
than the production value and we kill
excuses here at think media and decree
that resourcefulness is more important
than your resources so I would never
want you to listen to this episode and
be well I can't actually succeed then if
I don't have the fanciest stuff that's
not the point but as you are thinking
about the brand you want to build the
business you want to build and as you
experience some success I highly Rec
commend
reinvesting dollars into the elevation
and the evolution of your content it's
also a service to the viewer better
content better sounding audio better
video better editing makes a better
experience for the viewer and we are
servant leaders we are in the business
of adding value and giving the viewer
the best experience possible when you're
obsessed with the viewer experience you
will be obsessed with improving over
time the quality of your content and
then also up upgrading your gear another
benefit is the empowering of your
storytelling and this could look like
having different camera lenses that
create different looks different
lighting creates different moods and
different feels and can be flattering or
even just accurate if you're doing
Beauty tutorials and different things
you want to make sure the shadows and
the lighting and the colors of the
makeup of the skin tones there's a lot
of reasons why improving gear can
actually Empower your
storytelling and give you the tools
necessary to convey certain messages and
so what are the three big elements of
video If we go as broad as possible
before we Niche down the three big
elements is an acronym that's very
famous and you need to know it a v l
stands for audio video and lighting so
if I'm assessing a YouTube video and
essentially the totality of the
experience of consuming YouTube a few
things are happening one one audio so
what is the audio sound like can I
improve my microphone what is my
background noise am I going to be
blending music into this video how is
that Blended video and lighting really
work together because cameras crave
light and so what is my video quality
this could include lenses and does it
have a blurry background is it a nice
picture image what's the resolution is
it 1080p is it 4K and then lighting is
going to influence how the camera
performs how the video looks but it also
can add Dynamics do I want to have a
Vibe of RGB meaning red green blue
meaning color lighting do I want to you
know have my room kind of be blue or
have some color lighting behind me of
some kind all of these different things
could be an aspect of Av
VL one letter that we add at think media
is s and that stands for stabilization
and it could be a checklist of maybe
upgrading your gear to say am I going to
upgrade my stabilization get a try iPod
am I going to get a camera video am I
going to get a new camera am I going to
get a light kit and am I going to get a
microphone and and a broad categories
those are the three or four big elements
of video but what are the four primary
camera kits I'll tell you all four and
then I will describe each one number one
is a smartphone setup number two is a
desktop setup number three is a fancy
camera couldn't come up with a better
name than that and number four is a
specialty setup and so number one a lot
of us start creating YouTube content
with just our smartphone it's a huge
opportunity in fact with vertical video
and shorts all you need is your
smartphone and one of the amazing things
about the time we're living in is that
the video cameras on our smartphones
today are superior to the film cameras
just a few decades ago that were making
multi-million dollar movies and so
there's a lot of power in your pocket
now when we think about number one the
smartphone setup I think about the idea
that you can accessorize your smartphone
with avls you can get a tripod for your
smartphone you could get a plug-in
microphone for your smartphone or a
wireless microphone you can get
sometimes lenses to improve the video a
wide-angle lens that screws on to a case
oftentimes unnecessary maybe your iPhone
already does w wide angle but just
different things you could think about
and then of course lighting is going to
make the camera on your smartphone
better and so that's kind of one level
and what I would ask for you to do is to
pick which of these camera kits am I
using right now which one could I maybe
improve and which one could I upgrade to
because starting with your smartphone is
a great place to start and for a few
dollars literally $10 $20 wireless
microphone a $50 light kit a $20 tripod
you can really accessorize your
smartphone at a high level and again as
a reminder I know we're super tactical
in this episode this is why thinkgear
guide.com is so important I'm going to
be giving you these broad categories and
this broad thinking you might be
wondering Sean what are the best
accessories for my smartphone right now
that you guys that think media would
recommend that's at thinkgear guide.com
if you want to get super specific but
after a smartphone setup you may want to
build out a desktop setup at think media
we call this your battle station this is
essentially something that 99% of us if
not 100% of us already have because we
attend Zoom meetings or sometimes work
remote or work from home and so on the
most basic level if you have a laptop
with a webcam you have a desktop setup
you have the ability to cut connect to
the internet use your laptop microphone
your webcam video camera light from your
room and you could put out some video
now that's going to be pretty low
quality of course if you elevate that
you think about streamers you think
about people that record content at
their desk and we have the opportunity
to of course have a crispy camera one of
our favorite tools is like the cam link
and you don't even have to spend that
much money there's like a cheap $20
version which allows you to use a USB
port and plug an HDMI cable into it and
use a fancy camera and so your desktop
setup your battle station may be the
camera kit that you want to build out do
you want to create content from a home
office do you want to teach do you want
to interview other
guests and experts and create a video
podcast this is something that I
primarily do I'm actually sitting in
Anderson studios here in Las Vegas right
now with a crazy video podcast set up
and you know a lot of camera gear around
us with what's happening here but in my
home office with a USB mic and with a
fancy camera and with lights that are
mounted to my desk and with streaming
software like streamyard which is still
one of our favorites not even a sponsor
of this video but stream withth
think.com we love it so much and we'll
link up resources in the description and
that's my battle station and what I like
about it is it's a sustainable workflow
I love to teach I love to teach from
slides using something like PowerPoint
or keynote it might be something you
want to do if you're a business-minded
Creator or an educational Creator you
can react from a desktop setup there's a
lot of opportunities you can do from a
desktop setup of course the downsides is
it's not mobile right you're you're
stuck to your home office often times as
you build it out you're really stuck a
lot of wires and cables and it's not an
easy to move setup which brings us to
number three and I would call this a
fancy camera I would call this a
separate designated YouTube content
creation camera that you're setting up
at your office at your home in your
living room in your kitchen as you're
doing your cooking tutorials now little
footnote is that that fancy C camera
it's not like you want to buy a bunch of
them could also maybe be the fancy
camera you use for your desktop setup
these these categories could overlap you
can certainly use a smartphone at the
peak levels of quality if it's a newer
phone in 4k with good lighting and a
good microphone it might not be much
different than a fancy camera but when I
say fancy camera we're talking about
cameras that you maybe are looking for
and that are on your shopping list maybe
it's a Canon r10 maybe it's a Sony zv1
these separate dedicated YouTube cameras
that have a lot of benefits typically
the biggest one being video quality
frame rate maybe microphone input
headphone jack it's pretty impressive
how amazing video quality looks on
smartphones these days but just look at
the form factor of a smartphone it's
super shallow super thin sure the newest
phones the camera lenses are popping out
a little bit they're embossed a little
bit you know they're trying to cram as
much into this tiny form factor as
possible and then compare that to a
full-size lens on a camera that is
larger and more fancy what you're
getting there is you're getting larger
sensors that's where all the light and
data is collected so you have a bigger
sensor bigger than like half the size of
your phone if it's a fullframe sensor
it's a giant sensor you've got these
really nice lenses and these are not
essential to success on YouTube but the
reason people go and upgrade these types
of things is what we're using for this
setup right here like this is so crispy
because we're using full-frame cameras
with great lenses this would be the
fancy camera level so all of that to say
is you got to ask yourself the question
is that where I want to elevate my
quality to is that where I want to
elevate my brand to for my home office
for a vlogging setup for a travel setup
I think that's an important question as
well for as fancy as these cameras are
they actually aren't very good for
vlogging they're a little too heavy
they're a little too bulky for a video
podcast in a studio like we've set up
here and if you're listening to the
audio version of this episode and you um
haven't visited us over on YouTube this
might be an episode to check out so you
can at least see what the video version
of this podcast looks like but all of
that to say is that this might be the
leap you want to make and I want to
encourage you to be cautious on the leap
because as soon as you step into this
world I'm looking at tripods audio click
on modules to the Sony FX whatever with
XLR cables and we've got you know
lighting and Dynamics behind me it's all
cool and I encourage you to step up to
that level eventually but I've also
learned that complexity is the enemy of
execution so I'm a huge fan of using
whatever camera kit you feel comfortable
with right now and allows you to create
the best content for where you are right
now and to not really get ahead of
yourself cuz too many people get too
complex with their setup and then they
don't know how to use all the gear they
don't know how to set it up and then
number four before we go to the next
category is a specialty setup a
specialty setup so your specialty setup
is action cameras drones and Specialty
cameras you can use a GoPro for
everything you actually can live stream
from it you could use it as the computer
in your home office but I wouldn't
recommend it why because they do
terrible and low light they have a weird
really wide angle lens it's not weird
when your BMX biking or snowboarding or
even vlogging while you're hiking but
it's a little bit weird to use in
different environments your drone could
probably be used as a webcam but I
wouldn't recommend it like it's a little
sketchy so there's specialty cameras
which are worth considering upgrading
and typically I would recommend you add
them to your kit after you already have
some foundational gear it'd be money
spent in the wrong order to have the
best drone in the world but not to be
able ble to have your foundational
a-roll content be nice and crispy
because you didn't get that set up
unless of course the only footage you
were creating was Drone footage for some
reason and so those are the four primary
camera kits the smartphone setup the
desktop setup the fancy camera setup or
the specialty setup which one are you
using currently which one do you want to
use next for the full-time content
creator that's been doing this for
decades you probably have all of them
like at think media we use them all I
use my smartphone all the time I am
typically at my battle station I'm in
the fancy studio right now I've done
many snowboard trips and drone flights
and all kinds of things that we've
incorporated into videos and the
specialty setup is also good again for
storytelling like sometimes you may have
a drone just for the establishing shot
like if you think about sitcoms they
start with outside of the building you
think about Jerry sefel we start outside
of the restaurant and then you see them
sitting in now of course you could just
grab that shot
on the curb in Jerry sefel um the show
but with a drone you could have just an
establishing shot with a GoPro the
camera fits places that other cameras
wouldn't we're maybe getting a little
too complex but these are just I'm
bringing you into my process of how I
think about upgrading gear so let's hit
my checklist so what is on the video
gear upgrade checklist I want you to use
this to audit your setup and then make
plans for the future and as a reminder
I'm not suggesting that you need to
upgrade anything but when you think
about the things you could upgrade it
allows you to make a plan if you fail to
plan you plan to fail and I've learned
that it's important to have a vision
like I I remember drawing Visions for my
office how did I want my office to be
set up I was drawing it with pencil
thinking about the room thinking about
where desk could be vision is powerful
so even if you can't fully do this today
those who set goals those who have a
Clear Vision those who really get a
strong picture of their ideal future
maybe it's not next year but maybe in
the next 3 5 years you literally could
build out your dream studio and I want
to encourage you to be patient on the
journey I mean even here at think media
Kyle just revolutionized this video
podcast Studio that we've been building
out I've been at every stage of the game
I've been by myself filming videos and
my Loft at our echoey house with you
know my wife's Friends making noise and
being super frustrated because I didn't
have my ideal circumstances but I've
always had a Clear Vision and we've been
able to level up as we go so here's a
list of 12 things that you might want to
upgrade and you want to ask could this
help me go faster is this piece of gear
outdated or no longer producing is it
creating something frustrating like
number one is the camera do you want to
upgrade your camera and when we think
about cameras it's maybe not just to
have the latest fanciest camera there's
a lot of practical reasons you
absolutely should stretch yourself to
upgrade the camera maybe it's you're
doing long form content but your camera
has a 30 minute record limit absolutely
a frustrating thing that's you can work
around it but it sucks so if you just
solv that problem now you're saving
you're reducing stress you're increasing
speed maybe you're ready to go
4K sometimes when you use a camera the
different codex which is how it actually
captures the footage some are better
than others so you're like yes it's 4K
but I move it into my video editing
software and my computer crashes like it
can't even handle it that could be that
could mean you need to upgrade a
computer that also could mean mean that
uh you need a better camera that has a
better workflow and again the answers to
those questions whether your beginner
intermediate whatever budget you're at
is at thinkgear guide.com so I'm not
really going to shout out any specific
cameras here but number one do you want
to upgrade your camera number two do you
want to upgrade your lenses or get new
lenses this can be very meaningful Kyle
was just negotiating with me uh here on
the podcast set being like bro we need a
50 mm G G Master Prime for this setup
here because of the length of the room
good reasoning and I was like okay bro
so we got to spend three grand I mean
it's like a 2,000 something dollar lens
um but I was like okay let's do it you
know because we had is it in the budget
is it going to produce a look that we
want is it going to be used
for years to come especially when it
comes to lenses if you invest as they
say in good glass there's something that
could be used for years and a lot of
times they hold their value so you can
upgrade your lenses and really continue
to just add to your kit number three is
audio now we're already geeky if you're
still with me on the podcast I
appreciate you being here we about to be
get crazy or geeky here because in audio
there's multiple categories there's lav
mics shotgun mics wireless mics USB mics
fancy XLR mics there's all kinds of
different microphones so a lavalier is a
corded microphone typically right you're
going to connect that to your your shirt
to your jacket shotgun goes on top of
the camera you could Boom the shotgun if
you create some kind of a boom pole
setup Nolan did a really good video
about that there's a $15 boom M hack
boom mic hack that he did on our think
media channel wireless microphones are
popping right now you got the DJI one
the road one those also are very
multi-purpose see a lot of microphone
creators and gear creators realize that
like the road Wireless go actually has
an input so it could be a live lav mic
Wireless it could also itself just be
clipped onto your jacket it
also can be plugged into smartphones as
well as a DSLR or mirrorless camera so
there's an overlap here now USB mic is
basically limited to the desktop setup
but very important if you do want to
stream or record from your desk you
could do it with a USB mic or XLR wise
you can do the same in almost any
context but now you get into how what is
that XLR being plugged into that's just
a fancier level and so number one
cameras number two lenses number three
audio number four editing computer or
laptop this probably is under talked
about I think too many people are
overspending on their camera and they're
under spending on their computer your
computer assuming your editing and
putting together your content is
probably the biggest bottleneck to your
productivity if you can edit faster
render and Export Faster by the way your
internet connection would be a footnote
here too like spending money on
upgrading your internet speed in the
content creator career is a
no-brainer and getting a good editing
computer or laptop if you're on a tiny
laptop with a 14-inch Monitor and it's
got you hunched over at a weird desk
it's going to be hard to be super
productive as opposed to getting
multiple monitors perhaps getting a
monitor that allows you to edit quickly
see everything that you need to see so
that is a endlessly deep conversation
but probably some of your dollars bet
best spent is going to be on upgrading
your computer upgrading your laptop that
makes the largest impact to your time
number five tripod would it be helpful
to get new
stabilization are you interested in
getting a moving slider of some kind
that would be another stabilization kind
of category something that's going to up
your production value number six is
lighting huge you of course could do we
have big softbox Lighting in this case
um in this shoot we've got some light
poles that are RGB so they can add color
to the scene lots of different levels of
lighting and some lights are on camera
some lights attached to your monitor one
of the biggest things to consider with
lighting is the space that you have in
your room or around your setup
typically the bigger the softbox the
bigger the light source the more
flattering and better it is it feels
more like the size of the sun in terms
of how distributed the light is but if
you're in a tiny home office with low
ceilings it's going to limit the size of
lighting and perhaps how much of a
monstrosity it looks like different
aspects to think about with lighting
number seven is storage I always when
I'm upgrading think about SD cards hard
drives all those types of things um
storage for the future backups SD cards
is another one when it comes to speed
some cameras in 4k will not even record
in 4k if the SD card is not fast enough
um one of the things personally that I
do and I record a lot in my Seattle
office by myself and I'm solo up there
so I'm just I got my own workflow so I
got the fastest card reader possible I
made sure it could plug into my PC with
the fastest Thunderbolt possible and I
get the fastest SD cards possible so
that when I film
4K gigabytes and gigabytes of footage on
my Canon camera I can transfer it as
fast as possible and again maybe
Overkill and the other option is just be
patient you know use the gear you have
and wait but all of those links in the
chain the card reader speed the card
itself the transfer speed depending on
how much content you want to pop out
pump out are
important number eight is audio
interface or multi-channel podcast
recorder if you have an XLR mic you may
need an audio interface at a desktop a
very popular multi Channel podcast
recorder is the roadter there are other
tools like that if you want to do a
video podcast and have multiple guests
multiple inputs tools like that can be
incredibly helpful and and as we go
through this list some of these things
are not necessary it's just a way to
audit where are you now where do you
want to go what are some different
categories you might want to dip your
toes into number nine is a capture card
or a device for going live do you want
to use a fancy camera I mentioned the
cam link earlier for your desktop setup
do you want to use a fancy camera you
can plug that into a capture card
there's a little HDMI USB it's $10
sometimes during holiday sales um and
it's works pretty good I don't even know
which one is which because there's all
these different listings on Amazon that
are white labeled or whatever or you
just go with the fancy brand in a cam
link cam link 4K comes in at right
around $100 and oftentimes quite a bit
less and now you are able to have one
piece necessary for having a fancier
camera setup number 10 could be
specialty cameras are you in the mood do
you have the vision to get some kind of
action camera underwater camera drone
Action Sports this would also include
gimbals and accessories that could help
you film um with a another camera with
movement are you doing any kind of video
production or freelance video if you are
you you probably would already know all
this stuff but again part of the
checklist number 11 software huge
opportunity here can I upgrade my video
editing software can I invest in AI
tools to help me go faster can I invest
in project management tools especially
around the
holidays software companies usually give
big discounts can I invest in YouTube
tools Black Friday Cyber Monday sales
related to software and so I'd be asking
what is the hardware that I need and
that I want for the vision of the
content that I want to create in the
future and what is the software that
could help me go faster help me improve
my workflow as a solar Creator to be
more organized to work through projects
to optimize my videos quicker with
something like vid IQ can I to to
improve my overall workflow and to
potentially work with the team project
management software Etc and then number
12 before we get to the four questions
to summarize is accessories and this
list could be end list this could be
another 36 things but for example in
this room right now there are sound
panels there could be office upgrades
shelves mounts different ways to mount
your cameras Mount Your lighting see
stands you get into fancier stuff and
all of those things could be on your
list so that's my personal upgrade
checklist as we shop at think media
especially over the holidays we think a
couple things number one there are
legitimate discounts around Black Friday
Cyber Monday number two we also think
about year-end spending that we want to
spend strategically for there it being a
tax right off um and we're not just
trying to look for ways to waste money
money we're just asking in those 12
categories is there anything that could
improve our speed imp improve our
workflow and so I'm kind of getting
ahead of myself as we land the plane
remember go to thinkgear guide.com for
answers to your specific questions okay
Sean I would love to upgrade my fancy
camera I want to get a fancy camera
what's the best one under $1,000 perfect
we will answer that question um I'm
looking for the best microphones that
are Wireless on a budget what are the
best softwares that you recommend and
we're updating think gear guide actively
throughout the holiday season so that it
has some of the best sales and some of
the best things happening and going on
so definitely check that out but here's
four questions to summarize and if your
brain didn't hurt after this episode
you're amazing definitely smash like if
you watch on YouTube and don't forget to
rate and review the podcast wherever you
listen but four questions to separate
rise will this help me save time this
would be the item is in the cart you're
ready to check out this is like you can
justify to your spouse you know you
could justify
honey uh I need to buy more lenses this
was me back in um my whole life uh honey
I'm gonna buy this do you really need
that lens I don't know if I could answer
that question but if like honey I'm
going to buy honestly a new phone like
people critique sometimes the innovation
of smartphones I'm like the processor
itself meaning the processor of the
phone that goes faster the fact that the
apps load faster and it creates now mind
you I use my phone all day every day to
create content so it's always a
no-brainer will this help me save time
time is money and speed is power so if
yes then it's maybe a good move to make
and invest will this help me make more
money
can I make money directly with it early
on in my career I was making money doing
freelance video and doing YouTube hoping
that I would eventually be able to do
that fulltime so when I would buy gear I
was applying it to video production
itself that clients H hired me for so I
could justify and say like I actually
will make more money now sometimes I
could still produce the final result and
I just wanted some gear you know we all
have a little bit of gas gear acquis
acquisition syndrome you just always buy
just buying new stuff like oh this will
kind of make the shot look cooler like
the client didn't even care but of
course I cared about my craft and was
addicted to buying gear but ultimately
will this help me make more money
directly will this improve my content
and make me money indirectly can you
guarantee that improved video quality
will increase your monetization or the
sales in your business not necessarily
but brand lift right your brand being
elevated is a big deal so will this
improve my content and make me money
indirectly if it's a
notable
Improvement of your video I believe it
will
if your audience your viewers the people
who don't even know you that know you
yet the people who don't even know you
yet see that content See the EV
Evolution the elevation could be
powerful is this a tax write off I'm not
a CPA but it probably is and even if
you're new and this is a hobby if you
flip your mindset and set out with the
intent for YouTube being a business
content creation being a business you
having a little Independent Media
Company ran out of your house which is
the mentality I would recommend then
check with the CPA the cool thing about
everything we've talked about in this
episode is it's a tax write off and
taxes is one of the biggest bills you
will pay in your life it's probably your
biggest expense and it's unknown and we
do it unwillingly or unknowingly and so
I'm always looking for ways that I can
follow my passion which I love video on
content creation and save on my taxes in
the process this is one of those ways of
course that's not Financial advice final
two questions is this a need or a want
do I need this to improve the quality of
my AVL or is it just a want and then
final question what is my ideal vision
for my content let's just stream a
little bit and with no fear of missing
out or comparison maybe this isn't the
season where you upgrade to your full
dreams but what is a step you could take
towards your ideal vision and as you
start thinking about the dream of being
able to buy whatever you want shop
without looking at the price when it
comes to gear or to get brand deals and
sponsorships related to gear that can
light the fire again to hustle go make
some content with the with the gear you
already have go make some money build
your channel find some multiple streams
of income monetize so that you can live
into your ideal vision for your content
I want to encourage you dream big start
small and do the work and don't forget
to check out thinkgear guide.com my name
is Sean canel RS with YouTube channel
I'll see you in the next episode of the
podcast